you were my
choice i made a mistake
so
guys i'm gonna
kill this
damn depression stop
let's just all take a deep breath
jasmine gets physical with gino causing
producers to step in but believe it or
not this wild moment that leaves gino in
tears
turns into something so beautiful
it's a 90 day we love to see it moment
plus unfortunately
his girlfriend
it's official kim and usman are
officially girlfriend and boyfriend
i know right but that's not the gag but
the gag is
to kim's surprise usman finally decides
to get intimate we're having sex tonight
my friends dreams do come true and we
have to talk about how it goes down
is this what your random event yeah yeah
i'm dying hey 90 day fans fam it's
melisia
before the 90 days took a week off and
it came back swinging
this episode was so good let's kick
things off with jasmine and geno
[Laughter]
quick refresh
last episode jasmine found out that gino
sent nude photos of her to his
ex-girlfriend i was topless
completely showing off my breasts
and understandably she was devastated
why were you sharing something so
personal gino's excuse was that he
wanted to show his ex how hot his new
girlfriend is ridiculous
[Music]
i hate you
after jasmine cursed him out she packed
her bags and left the room which brings
us to this episode today it has been one
of the hardest moments of my life
i was never expecting gina to be this
way
jasmine is having a drink as she vents
about what's going on with gino to her
girlfriend over the phone
on top of heart feelings and alcohol
never being a good combination
jasmine starts to accept this idea that
gino sent the pictures to his ex because
he's still in love with her
which is a theory that doesn't really
make sense to me i mean if you're in
love with someone why would you send
them a naked picture of your girlfriend
i think geno sending those pictures has
more to do with his insecurities and
wanting to prove himself then it has to
do with him being in love but regardless
jasmine is running with it and she takes
off straight for gino's room no estoy
look at the producer i always wonder
what goes through their heads during
moments like this because they really
don't know what's about to happen and
jasmine you cannot predict her actions
not the kind of girl who who goes away
with it
you did bad to me you you'll pay for it
jasmine bursts into gino's room and the
way he's acting so nonchalant about the
situation just makes you want to shake
him around till he stops you saying nuts
to your ex of me that i trust on you
say what now
you heard her what you're gonna do
because i'm gonna sue you what nudes
sue him
gino clearly needs a wake-up call since
he wants to act oblivious
why gino
i'm showing on my
yeah your your breasts are showing
that's correct but they're not nudes oh
he's asking for it fire the cannon so
take off your damn
hat
and yes gino had another hat ready to go
in his handy dandy backpack when i
teased her taking off his hat in the
previous recap there were some good
comments rachel rose said quote her
taking off his hat probably screwed with
him more than anything she said for sure
and she's gone as far as calling him
trash
skye said quote hats off to jasmine
that's cute and steph said quote
jasmine's level of petty is how i aspire
to be for her to say those are news
after she takes his hat off
that's a gift everybody doesn't have
that she is definitely gifted in the
petty field plus it also speaks to her
intelligence
then you should hear my notes
all right on to a serious note here is
when things start to take a
heart-wrenching turn
jasmine finds herself back in geno's
room pouring her broken heart out and
you can literally hear her pain
that was part of my privacy
how can you do that
have the most to say something
do you want you want me to talk about it
where did you do it
wait i'm gonna let y'all keep watching
but jasmine's vocal cords
where did you do it
those things are strong
the situation is not funny at all but
i'm surprised she didn't lose her voice
i told you why why
to rub it into her sheet what is that
what i mean to you a
piece of meat
no that's not has nothing do you have
interest on hair no
you were obsessed with her
wrong
so what i broke up with her don't forget
oh okay
as gino continues to act unbothered
jasmine takes petty to the next level
by threatening to leak gino's nude
photos i'm
publishing
do you want me to do that
you
damn well it makes sense now
maybe if he was more secure with his
package he wouldn't have done these
things i told you it seems like this was
about geno proving himself do you want
to send my one here
texas go ahead
no
there is nothing to brag about
my pictures went hot
you are depressing
you're not a man
i don't want to see you anymore
that's your choice
my choice
kill him
i know she's pissed but i would not let
that go in one ear and out the other a
little bit of a red flag how did i
that was intense to say the least
the next day yesterday was like the
worst day of my life gino's reflecting
on everything that happened and he
breaks down in tears as he accepts that
he's probably lost jasmine for good
after all
i cost her
i've never seen her that mad before
he said that the last time
but anyway when it comes to jasmine she
says she was crying all night she's
actually preparing to leave the island
but she left her person gino's room so
she heads back to get it once she gets
there they decide to take a walk i just
feel really really terrible
it's a huge
selfish mistake on my part
i mean it just totally
destroyed you know all the good
connection that we had not so it
you know it just i'm really sorry about
that
um
i will never communicate with her again
i just want a chance you know
and why would i have to give you that
chance
you know that's a good question that
i've had to ask myself a number of times
why do i have to be nice
i love you very much
okay back to the conversation geno opens
up to jasmine about his love for her he
even calls her the perfect woman
i really don't want to lose you because
i'll never find someone as amazing as
you ever in this world
which leads to this unexpected
breakthrough that
had me in tears at the end of the story
you know i want what most people want
just to be loved
and i love you
you know that i do you know
what i do
i love you too
very much many people would think that
you're stupid why are you forgiving him
how he looked at me
he loved me i know that
that wild moment with jasmine swiping at
geno turned into something so beautiful
although they still have a lot of work
to do
this is what love is about right
compromise and the willingness to
forgive they were able to put their
pride to the side
listen and be vulnerable i'm so happy to
have you on my arms again
i was so worried as he should have been
now let's get real i know gino was wrong
for sending those pictures of jasmine
amongst many other things it was creepy
but
i don't think he initially did it to
hurt jasmine he just made that decision
from a very broken place within himself
i'm still hurt and it will take work to
heal from this
that doesn't make it okay
but if she's willing to look past it
what else can we say
he's going to have to work on whatever
led him to send those nude pictures just
like she's going to have to work on her
jealousy and temper but this is proof
even if it's ugly messy
toxic
love can conquer all okay i'm done with
the quotes
it's a 90 day we love to see a moment
for sure we're having sex tonight
really though
all right quickly usman and kim's
relationship is going somewhere
he finally decides to get intimate with
her after she told him if they are not
in a relationship before she leaves
tanzania
she's done with him for good hi jamal
how are you usman even takes a step to
chat with kim's son jamal for the first
time who is kayute by the way
here we are
i'm not shooting my shot i'm just saying
he's handsome usman thinks so too he is
your photocopier and he is
after usman assures jamal that he has
good intentions with his mom the time
finally arrives for kim to get what
she's been waiting for
and she has some anxiety
i'm a little nervous meanwhile usman is
getting ready in the bathroom looking
like future with his chain and shades on
are you ready for me
yes
is this what you're wearing to bed yeah
yeah
i'm dying
you're so funny uh-huh you're so funny
what are you doing
does he sing during everything
after they roll around for a bit usman
tells kim they are now officially in a
relationship i pronounce you
boyfriend and girlfriend i kind of have
sex with you wait you didn't tell me
that you didn't sound like that dude
that's what i'm having to say you never
told me that that's why we haven't
decided you were like really yeah i made
it yeah really you had one kim kissing i
cannot believe this is happening like
this is exactly what i came here for
have you ever have six oh god why do you
feel it here what does that mean i'm
asking you no okay today you experience
african ways that's what i'm telling you
okay he better be able to back all that
talk up unfortunately
his girlfriend that's so moving i did
not see an official relationship between
these two coming but
good for kim her many many many efforts
have not gone in vain
all right well next week it looks like
this high kim's on might start coming
down
nice couple yeah thank you
i really value our new relationship
between me and kimberly but the truth is
that is something i've been hiding from
her what are you talking about listen
could you do something that i need to
know about that's why i wanted to oh my
god
i swear to god bruce man
all right 90 day fans fam i am chatting
with mike soon about his relationship
with ximena so if you have any questions
you want me to ask drop them in the
comments and i will pick a few in the
meantime make sure you stick with et
because we are covering it all i will
see you next time
[Music]
you